aux mêmes les pays émergents les plus
dynamiques sont concernés par cette
crise alimentaire exemple l'inde
les taux de croissance à deux chiffres
ne suffisent pas à mettre fin à la
malnutrition correspondance arnauld
miguet arnaud le vert elles ont parcouru
des kilomètres pour confier leurs
enfants à cette équipe de médecins sans
frontières dans ce village reclus de
l'état du bihar
on ne voit pas des blouses blanches tous
les jours c'est même rarissime
pourtant des problèmes il y en or ici
plus d'un tiers des enfants de moins de
cinq ans souffrent de sous-alimentation
c'est un cas de sévère malnutrition
cet enfant mesure 68 cm et ne pèse que
saint cloud
normalement et sa taille il devrait
ference pour endiguer ce fléau
sachez de pâtes nutritionnelle et
médicaments sont distribués les enfants
de ce village seront normalement tirer
d'affaires dans quelques semaines mais
il y en a tant d'autres car en inde la
malnutrition tue plus de 6000 petit
indien meurent chaque jour parce qu'ils
sont mal nous amène à un enfant mal
nourri à un système immunitaire très
faible attaque donc des maladies
beaucoup plus facilement qu'un autre ici
il y en a qui ont des diarrhée ou de
fortes fièvres
c'est comme un cercle vicieux une
maladie entraîne l'autre
il feinte et pauvreté ne sont pas
éradiquées en inde dans ce village on
vit avec moins de 1,1 euro par jour
cela ne connaissent pas les fruits d'une
croissance indienne à 9%
il sut des castes les plus basses ils
sont ouvriers agricoles et encore quand
il trouve une terre à cultiver ses noces
en toutes nos plantations de céréales
sont perdus tout a été détruit à cause
des inondations
si l'inde ne connaît plus de famine
depuis la fin des années 60 elle est
loin très loin d'avoir gagné la bataille
contre la faim l'inde est donc la région
du monde la plus touchée par les
problèmes de malnutrition selon les
experts des nations unies 221 millions
de personnes souffrent de
sous-alimentation